can you believe it's been 14 years since
the first Incredibles movie they used to
have to hand draw Easter egg videos on
cave walls with a rock back then
thank goodness for technology am i right
the new Incredibles picks up right where
the first movie left off a lot of the
new film centers on the media frenzy
surrounding elastic girls come back at
one point we see a TV showing an old
archival interview with elastic girl
from back in the day this is the same
interview footage that opened up the
first Incredibles movie the Underminer
who appears in both Incredibles films is
voiced by John Ratzenberger known as
Pixar's good luck charm he's appeared in
every Pixar film to date he's ham in the
Toy Story films the abominable snowman
in Monsters Inc macked the truck in cars
Moustafa the waiter in ratatouille and
recently played Juan or depend on Zia
and Coco at one point and dimensions
that Jack Jack loves Mozart and that
playing it brings out his latent powers
we previously learned this in the 2005
short Jack Jack Attack in which Jack
Jack's babysitter Carrie made the same
upsetting discovery after turning on the
piano sonata number 11 also did anyone
else notice that the bad lady's name is
Evelyn Dever and if you switch around
the pronunciation it sounds like evil
endeavor we don't know whether
superheroes Dinah guy and gazer beem who
have a special connection to the Devers
parents in the new movie liked Mozart
but we do know how they died thanks to
the first Incredibles beyond just the
first Incredibles the film features rips
on the whiter Disney and Pixar universe
if you really pay close attention to the
backgrounds one of the hypnotizing
clocks we see in screen slavers
apartment bears the familiar three
circle Mickey Mouse shape Plus that
monorail running through downtown looks
a lot like the one they have over there
at Disneyland and Disney World
the familiar Pizza Planet delivery truck
from Toy Story also makes an appearance
in The Incredibles - universe and it's
been retro wised to fit into the 1950's
environment and take a close look at the
wallpaper and baby Jack Jack's nursery
it features a seal balancing the
recognizable yellow pixar ball on its
nose the ball has become a logo for the
company since appearing in the short
luxo jr. and the Toy Story films it's
somewhere in the background of
every single Pixar feature yes even the
good dinosaur beyond these little visual
details the entire world of The
Incredibles is a parody of comic book
superheroes so there's a lot of jokes
and references to familiar characters
the film opens with the concluding
action scene from the first Incredibles
movie this time we see the under minors
attack from the perspective of violets
classmate Tony right injured this is the
same technique Zack Snyder used to open
Batman V Superman dawn of Justice where
we see the conclusion of Man of Steel
but recreated from Bruce Wayne's
perspective
oh and Elastigirl laments that her new
costume is dark and angsty a common
observation made about the Snyder verse
she also references having had a
motorcycle and a mohawk in the past she
was like tank girl
now writer director Brad Bird is a big
Jonny Quest fan and has admitted the
classic cartoons influence on the
Incredibles the new movie makes the
connection featuring a quest billboard
in the city of new urban and a scene
where - watches an old Jonny Quest
episode on TV diggers Mindwipe
technology to protect the pars secret
identity closely resembles the one Will
Smith and Tommy Lee Jones use and men in
black which is based on a comic so it
counts here and consider that Winston
and Evelyn Dever are wealthy heirs
motivated by the untimely death of their
parents at the hands of a criminal just
like Bruce Wayne and Oliver Queen and
come to think of it Tony Stark
Evelyn's evil plan as the scream slaver
is to hypnotize people using psychedelic
images projected onto their TV screens
it's the same process employed by the
Riddler in Batman Forever
she makes fewer pop-culture references
and silly voices though and how about
that incredible it's named as an homage
to the Batmobile but most closely
resembles James Bond's tricked-out
gadget cars starting with Goldfinger
according to Brad Bird the big
Elastigirl verse screen slaver fight was
also inspired by the memorable train
showdown from the Bond film From Russia
With Love let's consider all of Jack
Jack's newly discovered superhero powers
all of which riff on powers we've seen
in the hands of other heroes he can
create inner dimensional portals like
Doctor Strange phase through walls like
Kitty Pryde morph into a monster like
the Hulk self combust like the Human
Torch shield laser beams from his eyes
like Superman or Cyclops or gazer beam
can turn huge like giant man or Apache
chief and can create multiple copies of
himself like the multiple man hopefully
he doesn't also develop reflexes powers
because those are just disturbing oh and
did you catch the movie title that's on
the marquee at the very end when violet
and Tony finally get to go out on their
date it says dementia 113 this is a dual
reference to both the animation
classroom that the Pixar guys went to a
113 and Francis Ford Coppola 'he's early
horror film dementia 13 whoa that's a
deep cut okay that's basically all the
incredible stuff we found in Incredibles
2 quick reminder to stay put for the
credits if you want to hear classic
versions of the main character superhero
theme songs is that an easter egg or
just Brad Bird being clever or am I
having a stroke let us know what you
think in the comments below
you